right now we're in such a great era for
creators because we're living through
the tick tockification of all social
media AKA for a decade you had to build
a lot of followers to get anything seen
now your first piece of content seen by
a million people that's profound so now
we're a whole different world where if
you do a podcast the clips get post on
Tick Tock and YouTube shorts and
Instagram reels which I think is going
to start following for a bigger virality
kind of Gap when I'm meeting Gap instead
of all your reels getting somewhat the
same amount of views now you'll start
seeing some things go viral but the
views you're getting are declining
because they have to have those views
for the virality if in that copy your
entire Instagram reels profile is listen
to that podcast and the podcast is the
default URL and in the post-production
of that reels there's a logo saying
listen to the podcast you're using the
content that you got from the podcast to
drive to subscriptions for the podcast
and it becomes a viral Loop